[Musique]
on
l'objectif premier donc c'est de pouvoir
relayer le travail de ces grimpeurs
l'idée c'était aussi l'objectif de
donner à voir donc cdaf d'une esthétique
très aboutie et on va dire de s'inscrire
dans la durée parce que c'est des
oeuvres qui sont éphémères l'apport en
disparaît deux par la météo etc
donc c'est un ebook c'est quelque chose
qui va rester
[Musique]
lebel
mais la terre dans la nature
[Musique]
sociale à la santé efficace logique là
la passion le message vaut pas la poule
est plus tôt voilà la ville place était
la responsable d'étagé
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont pas
forcément aller à l'école qui n'ont pas
forcément accès aux journaux et c est
donc pour eux comme le graffiti est dans
la rue il est vraiment accessible tout
de suite à tous avec des visuels qui
sont très percutant à des couleurs qui
sont souvent très présente
[Musique]
ça fait des années que par exemple
d'octane en place avec la caravane
graphique santé des campagnes de
sensibilisation ça peut être contre le
sida le paludisme où il travaille avec
des médecins pour donc parler à la
population pendant des graffitis sont
réalisés avec des messages de prévention
[Musique]